[Music]
is there a way of measuring which
courses
professors or fields of studies actually
model intellectual debate versus
advocacy
because the reason why i'm asking is
that then the people on the
grievance study side or the extreme
radical left side might say well it's
all social pressure everybody is so
even in the sciences there's social
pressure to not speak up so you're
saying that we're playing an ideological
ideological game but you are as well in
the sciences
well certainly i i you know i i i i say
that
um what i call liberal study this is the
intellectual engagement well i mean
that's an ideology
something one would value and i want
universities
to be places where that's what is valued
intellectual engagement
and other people don't
that's fine
but a university i think should be
should be a place of of
intellectual engagement so getting back
to the question of measurement
is there a way of measuring which fields
or professors or courses
do not subscribe to this or subscribe to
it on the spectrum
yeah i can't imagine a measurement a
metric but i do think there are
hints pieces of evidence and one is to
talk with the professors or look at the
course descriptions or the mission
statements or whatever and if the
mission statements or the professor or
whatever is
it says that uh you know
he or she means to create people who
appreciate
social justice who will work for the
betterment
of some group of people or whatever
then that's evidence that there's going
to be a
an advocacy thrust to the
to the course if it's something like we
will engage
intellectually in um discussions about
the nature of race or the nature of
prejudice or whatever
then um that's probably a study that's
probably where people are
putting theses on the board and
investigating their virtues and vices
and what would the professor say
when you bring up that you're not being
intellectually honest or laying out all
the arguments or allowing your students
to
speak in a manner that seems like their
dissonance
well often enough one's ignored um you
know
and people are free to ignore criticism
um
i like to uh i i like to discuss these
things at a more general level and not
um uh directly at any particular
professor because that gets people's
backs up and again
it might be another way of exerting
pressure
but writing and talking generally about
teaching about the mission of the
university the goals of the university
uh that can incline people to think that
um
to think twice about what they're doing
and perhaps try their things
now there was a case where i was sitting
in a cafe once and a professor came up
to me
uh who i had criticized in print for
um a course that was teaching
uh how to protest rather than being a
an intellectual engagement with the
phenomenon of protests
and certainly the phenomenon of protest
is a perfectly respectable academic
subject
let's go and study it and even by going
and studying it if you're
if you're keen on advocacy for a
particular thing you might learn a trick
or two and that's fine
but the course seemed to be about
teaching people how to
um agitate for
some specific ends and and i was writing
in a
in a student newspaper how i thought
that this was um
uh uh not in the spirit of uh of what i
call liberal study
not a university should be so we sat
down we had a discussion we talked for
about 15 minutes and
um i admitted that i might have
overstated
in my article the degree to which this
was a
a how to uh promote social justice
course
but he also thought that perhaps uh he
strayed away from the academic mission a
bit so it was rather satisfying
discussion from my point of view because
we actually talked about
an important matter and uh found
something like a middle ground
[Music]
you